I got myself a Tobii Eye Tracker
Y E S
That thing that makes you look at bOObs
The- this. If you can see this
On my desktop I've got a little circle
And it's showing exactly where I'm looking
Which is SO useful because the eyes are the windows of T R U T H
And justice
Your eyes basically tell you what you want
Or what you THINK you want
Maybe what you don't even know you that want
But you can see it now because it's in your eyes
So, with this, what kinda person does it say about ME?!
Er- of the things that I'm looking at
You know what I mean?
Does that make any sense? It doesn't make any sense ;-;
So, if I was looking at a picture
And it was thi- oh.. Yeah..
*stutters* yeah..oh...so...it
So basically... Yeah.. That works..
*laughter*
I .. uhhh
Yeah. Think of this. Think of what I'm doing right now as a calibration to make
My brain and my eyes are working properly. You know hand eye coordination.
I just want to see if it is reflected in what we got.
*laughter*
Yeah okay nothing wrong here
*laughter*  Yeah
Oh my
Okay so you get a general sense of like what that is
But that's not *slams desk*
That's not *desk shatters and man screams* that's not the main reason about this.
The whole point of this in knowing where your eyes goes is to
show you what your preferences are. Because where your eye is drawn
Is what really matters to you most.
So what I have here are a bunch of match-ups.
Basically,
Pictures that I have prepared,
that I don't particularly know the order of
umm, where I have things matched up one against the other.
So, for example:
If I close my eyes,
and then open them.
And I looked at the puppy first!
*children cheering* Yayyyyy!
Wouldn't you know it?!
I prefer the puppy!
My eye was drawn to the puppy, do you see what that says about me?
(You like dogs?...)
So I'm gonna go through these,
And you guys just mark down my preferences,
*breath*
And that will tell a story of my s o u l (finish undertale you coward that we love)
Of my true self, of my heart, my deepest heart.
That's what that says about me.
*violin music*
Bunny!
(My bunnies are cuter though)
That's so cute! Look it!
Not that the piggy's not cute - the piggy's cute, that piggy's really cute,
but my eye was drawn to the bunny.
Specifically that bunny's eyes.
If I was a hunter...
Pew! Dead.
(Bunnies make great pets)
*violin music*
Oh, Star Wars!
Okay, see-
it's not that I don't like Star Trek!
I love you Picard. [sound effect: "NO!"]
You know, I, I remember Star Wars.
*laughs* Maybe it's cause he's holding a gun at me, [background: "give me your fukin money"] and that's morally threatening.
*violin music*
Oh, minion.
*stumbles over words*
I didn't necessarily expect that,
except maybe it's because that minion is...
absolutely, utterly terrifying. Like-
unbelievably, the eyes are just-
(its also because the yellow is the most visible colour which gets your attention first)
a horror show of death.
And as much as, like...
*a lot of stumbling, mismatched sentences and coughs ;)*
*cough cough*
*more coughs*
I was inspecting Shreks, umm, *gone wrong*
g i r t h, there
*chuckle*
*Shrek impression* ????, me eyes are up here!
That's my Shrek impression, do you guys like it?
Umm, nothing to speak of down there!
Uh, Mr Minion. *cough/grunt*
*violin music*
Ohhhhhh
Boobs v Butt!
I'm not sure which one I went to, I think it might've been butt?
I'm pretty sure, that was probably very much butt.
Boobs v Butt, I think this says that I'm an ass man.
[sound effect: "WRONG!"]
*violin music*
Oh! *laughs* Boobs v Shrek.
Well, boobs won. (Liar.)
By far.
[WRONG AGAIN]
Not that I don't, not that I don't-
Really appreciate your boobage there, Shreky.
Uhh, but,
to be perfectly honest I don't think you would've won that one anyway, so uhhh.
Yeah, boobs.
*sad piano music*
*violin music*
Ah, yep, sorry, minion!
[sound effect] "why you always lyin'?"
Although my eyes did snap to those eyes just in real quick,
real quick lil' tizzy there
I think that's because there's something very THREATENING about those eyes,
but I think boobs still won.
*violin music*
Oh ohhhh! Puppyyyyy!
*Laughter*
PUPPY! :D
Puppy
*Laughter*
Puppy beep boo
*violin music*
Ohh penis
*Mark dying*
That is a BIG Old Dick
that *giggles* that is *continues laughing*
Ah that's quite a.. that's quite a cock and balls right there
*laughter*
Sorry boobs uhhh I wish it weren't so but
something about a
I think this might just be because a big ole dick on your screen
ain't the ah...   ain't the most
*heavy breath*
I-it's kinda surprising if a dick just appears out of nowhere.
*continues staring at the screen*
Yeah that's why I'm going to go with that one
*violin music*
(laughing) God damn it
Ahh
Uhh
*cough*
PeNiUSssss
peniUSSSS
*violin music*
God damn it. Alright you know what
I would have thought
the Minion is very phallic shaped
But uhh something about that
dick and balls real eye catching.
*violin music*
OH Beavis
*wrong answer buzzer*
*violin music*
* laughter *
* more laughter *
Ah that is-that's just a butthole
* drawn out laughter *
*violin music*
*stares at Pewdiepie first*
OH noo
oh NOOOO
I think it's just because it's a big red symbol
(in deep voice) I am sorry I am just
(intense) ABSOLUTELY LIVID
at the moment
I .... have some 'splaining to dooo
*violin music*
*laughter*
Alright well this isn't a fair match up
I *laugh* as charming
as Felix's smile is here
and as dapper as he looks.
There is still just something shocking about a big ole dick
just suddenly appearing
on my desktop.
Just something about it is very disconcerting.
*violin music*
Ah dick!
Alright dick again
If my parents walked in on me right now
I don't think I could explain what I'm doing
cuz I would tell them that I'm trying to reveal the truth of my soul
(laughing) and then they would still
*deep breath*
Have SO MANY QUESTIONS
*glitching laugh*
*violin music*
(laughing) Ohh hohohohoho
*laughter*
*breathes in*
Welllll
Well shiver me timbers apparently
a rock that looks like a (laughing) penis
is more eye catching than a (laughing) real penis
I don't know what the truth of my soul is
and what this says about me but
boy howdy
I am leaving
*violin music*
Dog!
Shrek!
*violin music*
Minion!
Okay now I feel bad because
I can't say it's because T-Series was bright red logo
now I (laughing) gotta just gotta say
Anyway whatever
*violin music*
Awwww a cute pup
*glitching violin music*
Huh wa haha
huwa hah
Ahh haha
ah
Alright well I think this one is obvious just because this one is like
that's actually scary
and uhhh
I think.. I think biologically a threat
A terrifying threat would be much more eye catching  than
*total silence*
*scary noise*
*more glitched violin music*
Ahh uh no the boobs
I.. I swear I wanna look at the boobs but it's like
which pair of eyes do I wanna look at here
(deep gargled) Oh noo
*strange reversed violin music*
Ahhh NOO
AHHH
I ca-(laughing)
Just the
It's the big ole
It's the curse of the dick
Like just a big ole dick
It's just a.. I'm sorry
maybe because I'm desensitized to this picture now but
(laugh) I just
I uh it
I'm going to have to replay the footage and really slow that down
(deep) DISAPPOINTED
I will wait for the judges call on that one
Okay so I think I revealed the truth of my soul
I'm not sure if I'm happy with the results
I think the ranking is
Uhh
Penis beats everything
Its like you're playing rock, paper, scissors but you're play Shrek, Minion
Uh boobs and penis
It's like rock, paper, scissors or Shrek, Minion, and boobs
But then penis is like your friend going like
(dumb voice) I got dynamite
He blows up everything. So penis just
gets in your life and blows up everything
So
That's my Tobii Eye Tracker. That's.. that's what that is
I don't feel too proud of myself
*horse lip noise*
But anyway thank you everybody so much for watching
Uhh if you got other ideas for
Tobii stuff that I can do or stuff with the eye tracker
there are games out there that are eye tacker enabled
Um
So if you wanna let me know what you want me to do
let me know down in the comments. I've got some ideas myself.
I'm going to do that whole don't look at boobs and butt
challenge
but the hard mode is going to be don't look at the penis (laughing) challenge.
Which I think is a different
different challenge entirely
So anyway
Thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always
I will see you
in the next video
bye bye!
(have a good day :D)